hello Berlin we've made it to week ten
this is the last stop on the startup
school tour we have something kind of
special today so adore and I are doing a
presentation together and it's all based
on numbers from the last nine weeks of
startup school she's going to sort of
kick it off and what we're going to do
is probably talk like hopefully twenty
minutes and then we'll open it up to Q&A
taking it to all of your questions there
anything else you want to talk about and
then we'll have like more mingling and
eating and such until though we have to
kick you out and go have you work on
your company or apply to I see that's
what you still have left to do at 8:00
p.m.
Fedora 5:00 5:00 a.m. or Linn time 5:00
a.m. Berlin times so funny
all right thank you Kevin
thanks for being here so Kevin said my
name is Vidura one of the partners at YC
and we're just gonna go over what we
learned during start-up school so it's
week ten we made it
congratulations the startup school team
has been in the past few weeks traveling
around the world visiting cities where
there's lots of start school founders
we've been we've done 20 events at this
point over 15 cities and we've
interacted with over 2,000 founders in
person so similar to how we started we
wanted to end start-up school by looking
at the numbers most of you don't know
this but Service School actually grew a
lot during the course itself when we
held orientation back in July end of
July we're around 20,000 founders and
21,000 startups with over 20,000 people
auditing the course just for the content
and as we let more people in during the
course as of today the number swells by
over 40% so you'll see we have now over
40,000 founders in start-up school and
over 30,000 startups there are over
77,000 people actually subscribed to the
content and over yeah what's with the
number of people increasing between 30
and 50 percent really cool that female
founders increase the most here so one
of the things that we want to look at
was whether startup school have made a
difference so we look at that the last
two batches to see how last year's
participants compared to the rest of the
population in regards to their ability
to get funding from YC so in the end
from the past two batches 9.7 percent of
start school applicants that applied got
an interview versus nine point one
percent of non start school applicants
got interviewed that means six point six
percent he did start school six point
six percent you had a higher chance of
getting interviewed and we think this
year it will be much much higher because
we focused the course a lot on helping
you build that application and just feel
start up on the right things to get get
those questions done well alright so if
you look deeper into the numbers as of
today 106 start school companies have
been accepted into I see for a group of
people who are more likely to get
interviewed you think they look amazing
on paper they got until I see but you
would be wrong
started school founders accepted into YC
are surprisingly different in every way
in every city we visited founders are
constantly asking us to see if YYC still
wants to accept companies that are not
perfect that are like them but not
perfect and the big takeaway is is that
why she is not afraid of warts and we
can assure you no startup we've ever
accepted has been perfect so dig a
little bit deeper in 206 companies from
startup school that has gone to the YC
already 40 of them had no traction when
they got in so that means no revenue no
users yet 57 also had no revenue 50 had
no funding whatsoever meaning zero zero
dollars cash in the bank some of them
didn't even incorporate yet quite a few
of them were still working at jobs or
might have in college and still working
part-time 40 of them applied previously
so this is one of the things as we
encourage you even if you don't get in
is to keep trying again a lot of people
apply three to four times I've been on
that for that it's try they get in some
of the companies we didn't really like
the idea they applied with and they
actually pivot it during the batch and
so that counts for a dozen of them and a
lot of them applied late so by time you
watch this video you're applying late
and we still encourage you to apply and
final this is the most asked question in
our tour which is if I'm a solo founder
should I still can I still do YC and the
question is absolutely yes tenant single
founders got in from start school we
average around 10 percent of the batches
around solo founders now if not a little
bit
that we highly encourage every team to
have a technical co-founder but if you
don't it does not disqualify you in fact
three of the start of school companies
that have gone into YC or not technical
all right
so how can you replicate their success
it's very simple and we're about to I'm
about to repeat a lot of things we've
already said during the startup school
but the best thing you can do is when
you talk about your startup there's a
question on the applications what are
you making and that is to be very clear
or it is and if you've watched Kevin's
lecture from a couple weeks ago the next
few slides will seem very familiar so
one is be clear on what you're working
on know jargons not only be clear but
don't use all the words in dictionary be
very concise and how you get your point
across so to be even more specific on
that question on the application of what
are you working on startups that I got
that have gotten accepted to YC use on
average 78 words to describe what they
do so somebody at words might seem a
little or a lot to you but in fact what
it does is it looks like this it's two
paragraphs and gets your point across
well so if you have something that looks
longer than this and you should really
go through your description and start
cutting words and finding sentences that
you really don't need to have them there
alright so if this is what a description
should look like what should a
description not look like well here's an
example of this is literally this is
actually one of my favorite ones because
as you'll see next of a description that
did not get accept or again interview so
we couldn't fit the whole thing in here
but if you read like this guy or I
forgot who the founder is but he
basically knows he needs to write
something short but decides to write a
wall of text in fact that wall of text
was the longest description we got of
all applications in the past two batches
it was over 2,000 words
obviously please don't do this it
doesn't help us understand your startup
any better it actually just confuses
more and frustrates us it basically
tells us that you don't know how to be
efficient when it comes to getting
people to understand what your startup
does so if you think about it if this is
how long it takes you to describe what
you do if you can imagine when you come
in for a 10-minute interview you'll the
interview be done before you even you
know finish your description furthermore
what culminates up an end of YC itself
is a two-minute demo day pitch so again
that's even less time to get your point
across and so you really need to start
practicing now on how you deliver your
how you deliver on how you explain your
company the good news is in start-up
school when you apply or when you've
registered you have to fill out your
company description and we actually
forced you to write it in less than 200
characters or less now this is a
histogram of a number of characters of
words that startups pool companies use
and you can see that a lot of you got
through the two hundredth character and
probably want it to write more but have
to stop because we forced you stub it
and the result as this description
actually averages it's around 40 words
or less
so by force we've made you do it less
than an average of 78 words so that's
good news so when you transfer your
descriptions to your IC application we
suggest you to not expand much further
than what you've worked the number of
words you've already used all right so
one thing we noticed and we're worried
about was the lack of editing on your
hand when you've entered in that sort of
school description so over the course
over the 10-week course we've been
trying to help you make that description
a little bit better in fact a lot of the
group sessions were designed to help you
with that but as you've been practicing
pitching every week money of you didn't
actually go back into your profile and
edit your company profiles with a better
description it's actually the one thing
we do at YC to help startups more than
anything else is really get
there one or two liner and there's
descriptions so the next article we're
going to probably focus more on helping
you do that and forcing you to document
to your changes over time the media
number edits is only one so we think
that most likely the description you
have right now can be improved on
drastically so if you need more tips on
how to do this well Kevin's last lecture
how to evaluate ideas part two that's
the name on the YouTube channel please
please go watch as you see a lot of the
slides were lifted from there so all
right I'm gonna let Kevin take over for
the next bit you guys submitted a lot of
data to us every week we ask companies
to let us know about their progress if
you've got an email from the Kevin
inspirational bot then you know that
basically we're trying to get you to
just spend 10 to 15 minutes at the most
so just tell us like what's been going
on with your company and in the last
nine weeks that's been over a hundred
and twenty four thousand pieces of data
and so we've got a lot of interesting
insights from that the first thing is
concerning what start school companies
considered their biggest obstacle so not
surprising to us but oh but it is kind
of worrisome number one was funding you
we were worried about lack of resources
and you could move forward as a result
of not having money and the other one
that's interesting on here is like
meeting a co-founder at number six and
the reason I would kind of point these
out is that if you look at what people
said actually improve their KPI the
metric that they considered mattered the
most when we did the text analysis it
looks very different so you think your
biggest problem is one thing but the
thing that would actually help you the
most are very different so number one of
course is launching getting out the door
once you launch you can move that KPI
which is wonderful other stuff on here a
lot of it concerning product the thing
is dealing with the users if you're
having problems where the difference
between what you think your biggest
obstacle is and
that makes the biggest difference 2kpi
are two different lists like this watch
a doors lecture she talks about how to
prioritize your time it's actually doing
really really well on YouTube it's the
fastest spreading one a lot of people
have found her tips in there on how to
think about your to-do list in a much
more KPI driven way very very helpful we
asked you to talk to your users and tell
us what did you learn from them and
these are the top things that people got
not surprisingly they're focused on
product and basically the best thing you
can do is make something people want
and the top two insights because they're
focused on conversion and modernization
I've got two lectures that we did
back-to-back on improving landing page
conversion and pricing so those are good
places to start if you want to improve
things for your users now actually most
of the participants unfortunately in
start-up school did not launch and so
when you were considered not launched
the KPI that you track was weeks to
launch and so these are the numbers and
how they came out people on average went
from WTF weeks to launch of seven weeks
down to five weeks at the end for some
reason that should have been to zero
right now what's actually super
interesting here is that the median
weeks to launch is about four so that
indicates that in the average there it's
being actually very much impacted by
people having very large weeks to launch
that's really bad and so if you haven't
already you're gonna find a theme here
for this presentation watch Michaels
lecture on how to plan an MVP he talks
about how you should only be making the
first version that takes just a few
weeks to launch and so even that meeting
is double the number that we recommend
for our companies in that talk he also
coined a new term that we've been using
is herb's going out YC the heavy MPP
and this is if you're a hard tech or
biotech company you might need to build
something that's a little more
substantial and in fact you guys
actually believe you do need to you're
almost double the number of weeks to
launch that you estimate and
unfortunately if you look at the grass
by comparison so this is the average
startup school weeks the launches that's
going slightly down over time this is
the biotech our tech people
you guys actually go up over time so now
add features over the course of the week
and that's not good because actually
from our experience funding over 200
biotech our tech companies is that they
should be following different advice or
rules than other companies which is why
we recommend if you haven't watched it
watching Jared's lecture on advice or
biotech in hard tech companies he BC
talks about seven wonderful examples of
YC companies that built a much lighter
weight heavy MVP and creative ways of
getting their company off the ground
even though they don't have millions of
dollars and lots of time to build the
first version for the companies that did
launch you guys did great so this number
represents the percentage of the weekly
updates were submitted that came from
companies that launched so at the
beginning of the course a third of the
weekly updates came from launch
companies and by the end half of them
were from large companies that's super
awesome
in fact 2253 startups we can actually
track switch from weeks to launch to a
different KPI during start-up school to
put this into perspective for us it took
over 10 years for Y Combinator to launch
that many companies through our program
and in search while we did it in 10
weeks doors and talk about group
sessions all right as you know every
week during summer school we matched you
with other startups to help you practice
talking about your own startups and we
rated everybody and would rate each
other on three metrics
did you understand this idea were you
excited about the idea and would you
want to work with the founders for the
first question over time you guys got
better at explaining
as you can see the differential from
each week to week was over 0.1% to put
that a perspective a zero point percent
increased represents almost 100 startups
because of the number of startups in
start-up school and by the end there was
a 7.1 percent increase overall alright
in terms of improving on selling
yourselves you guys also got better over
time there was a nine point five percent
improvement from the beginning the
biggest improvement was actually getting
other people excited about it your idea
and so there is a 17 percent improvement
since the beginning we know that there's
a lot more work that needs to be done
here we want to in the future create a
lecture to help you get better at
getting other people emotionally excited
about your ideas being old they do that
helps you with things like recruiting
and getting customers on board and also
investors on board in the future if you
want more help in structuring your
investor pitch Kevin Kevin's lecturer
for a second lecture it was called how
to evaluate startup via ideas part one I
would go watch that all right so while
the quantitative ratings made it easier
to get founders involved startup school
founders loved it when you actually gave
each other qualitative feedback comments
after the group session we were amazed
to see how supportive everyone was with
each other in terms of giving this
feedback in fact over 93,000 pieces of
qualitative feedback were created during
the course so many of you have offered
to help with introductions to customers
often whispered words of encouragement
that we know made a huge difference to
someone struggling to make the magic
happens one of the main reasons for
doing these group sessions together it's
sort of like emotional support in group
therapy because we're all going through
the same things and so I think that
achieved the results we were looking for
in that sense the generosity we saw in
the comments is what makes doing doing a
start-up and a batch incredibly powerful
so thank you for everyone for taking the
time to do this it really means a lot to
everyone on the flip side not all of you
are great
a bunch of you know showed so 19 percent
of startups who requested a
participating group session did not show
up boo yes so this graph shows updates
requests for group sessions and
attendance and no-shows over the last
nine weeks
oddly enough 23 percent of starts to
submit a weekly update didn't even
request a group session we're looking
for the next time for the next course of
how to make this easier and more
convenient for startups because we think
that this has been actually helpful not
just in improving your pitch but also
for moral reasons interviewed
interesting enough this graph actually
shows where we messed up in the first
week so that big gap there between
number of updates submitted and requests
requested shows that you guys were very
confused about how to request group
sessions at the very start of startup
school and that's why we gave it to one
or free me on that first one and that
sort of stabilizes as we get down you're
never just like how you guys are
probably using metrics to help improve
your startup we are - as well okay so we
also asked you guys to submit how you
feeling
what's your morale I'm working on your
startup and overall out of one hundred
and twenty four thousand pieces of
weekly feedback and you can see the
trend is you got a little happier over
time but we actually want to just
segment the south to see what actually
really impacted and what made a big
difference for morale for companies and
so it led to some of the most
interesting and unique insights from the
program for us at Y Combinator first one
ethical startups no surprise are happier
you're just able to get more done one
thing to notice is you'll think that the
difference here and changes are small
but because of the amount of data that
were collecting across each one of them
that these are pretty statistically
significant and so if you're looking to
be quantitatively happier these are ways
to do it if you launch you're a little
bit happier than the unlaunchable one
thing that helped a lot of companies to
rethink how they thought about launching
was watching cats
check on how to launch again and again
it just really change that bar from
being a launch that requires press to
being one that is just about shipping
and deploying on a regular basis if
you're full-time on your startup feel a
lot happier obviously probably because
you can also make more progress if
you're making money you're happier the
whole algorithm money can't buy you
happiness not true adores got a good
lecture on this on focusing on revenue
how to set kpi's it's her first lecture
from the startup school and I actually
think it's one of the unappreciated ones
it's the lecture that really talks about
why 99% of you should be focused on
revenue and be honest with yourself
about whether you're actually doing that
or not here's one that's really
surprising people who did not flake on
group sessions were way happier than
people who did basically feeling like
you're doing a start-up and having other
people to talk to you and being part of
the community and batch meant that
you're happier working in your startup
than those who did not participate at
all the happiest cohort was actually
people who were in teams and this is
actually one of the main reasons we
always say that we want companies that
try to have co-founders it is so hard to
do a start-up on your own and this is
usually morale is the thing that kills a
lot of companies and founders and so
again when we talk about we want you to
try to have a co-founder it is to help
with the longevity of your startup not
because we just don't want to select
those that don't have teams and then
this was the most surprising thing that
we learned from startup school that
founders and teams that talked to users
were way happier over time than those
who didn't and what's interesting about
these two cohorts is that the people who
did not talk to any users at all they
were the only cohort that actually had
morale get worse over the course of
Skol in the nine weeks that those who
didn't so the lesson the moral of this
morale are you feeling sad talk to users
it doesn't take very much to do it the
median number of users that start school
teams talk to with just three users a
week it actually provides a ton of
insight for you but apparently it's
better than Prozac if you want more
information about how to talk to users
and a better way of handling that in a
sort of structured way that helps you
improve your product watch eric's
lecture from the first week of startup
school let's bring it home a door in
summary from this presentation star
school helps you get interviewed
it's okay not to be perfect like you can
get accepted even if you have a wart try
to write your description in 78 words or
less prioritize launching you're
probably taking too long to launch
practice makes you better at pitching
talking about getting people to
understand you get excited and want to
work with you
and lastly talking to users make you
happy which is why we're going to switch
over to talk to you guys thank you so
much
[Applause]
you
you